Let's go next to Stephanie Paul from Paris,
France, one of my favorite places in the world.
Stephanie, I'm so jealous of you.
Oh, thank you very much, David.
I've been listening to the show for quite
think about two years and also it's.
It's absolutely fascinating.
Thank you.
Oh, the question I want to ask you is, how
on earth did Amy Kearney, Barrett actually
get elected or put into her position?
Because in 2016, I think when Barak Obama
wanted to do the same thing, the Republicans
blocked him or at least didn't want it to
happen.
And Barak Obama seemed to have just been like,
oh, OK, I won't do it.
Yes, he did.
It doesn't seem that way, doesn't it?
Yes, it's bizarre.
No, you are.
This is perfect because.
You're getting exactly it's like what?
What exactly happened, like they got away
with it.
They clear they came up with the Republicans
in the Senate, came up with a bogus reason
to block Merrick Garland in 2016.
And then now they said, oh, that explanation,
that doesn't really matter.
And with a week to go before the election,
they confirm Amy CONI bury it.
It's a travesty.
And this is why Joe Biden, if elected.
And if Democrats take the Senate, should expand
the Supreme Court.
Period.
Full stop.
That's it.
But you're you're you're despondency over
what happened is accurate.
Batik, they.
They can't get her out of power now that she
is actually in it.
She could be in a pinch.
She could be impeached theoretically.
But that never happens, you know.
Oh, okay.
Perfect.
Thank you so much.
It's a pleasure to speak with you.
Stephanie, wait before you go.
So it sounds so it sounds like from your accent
you're French, but you learned English in
the U.K., is that correct?
I'm ha.
I'm half and half actually.
Yes.
Wow.
And what is Paris like?
Best of both worlds or the worst of both worlds.
How is Paris given that?
It's a little bit sad, actually.
There's a lot of a lot of confusion as to
what are the new rules going to be or we're
going to have a lockdown.
Right.
Going to have a lockdown just for the weekend.
That's one of the ideas that has been floated
at the moment.
There is a sense of a lack of control.
Yeah, but at the same time, I think Macau
has done, in my personal opinion, a better
job than many other leaders.
Yes.
I'm not 100 percent sure how or why the virus
is propagating as much as it has and is doing
now.
But I am amazed that we.
France has is unfortunately going through
such an increase in numbers that we're seeing.
We had 500 plus deaths today, potentially.
Yeah, we have been having numbers in the 14
40000, which is unprecedented.
We didn't even have this at the height of
the lockdown.
Right.
A few months ago.
So it's very worrying.
There's a real sense of fatigue and the stress.
But, you know, Parisians will continue to
be Parisians a sort of year.
But it's alright to talk very well.
Right.
And let listen let me ask you this.
When I when I go to Paris, I often will stay
in the area of Bellville or République.
Are those actually respectable neighborhood
where I live?
That's where you live.
Beautiful.
And let me ask you this.
Have you ever been to a restaurant?
I believe it is called ravioli.
Ch'ien Wah du Nord.
S, of course.
Yes.
Is it.
Can you tell us a well, he's.
I tell the audience.
There are no better dumplings than at that
restaurant.
Is that correct?
It does affect.
And actually those dates run by a family.
Yes.
And they make all the dumplings fresh during
the day.
Right.
There is a set number of dumplings made.
When they're finished, they're finished.
So, you know, it opens at seven thirty PM
shop and all the dumplings are gone by maybe
10, 30.
Now, let me ask you one other question.
Do you get the dumplings steamed or grilled?
You can choose.
No, no, no.
I mean, I know, I know, I'm asking, what do
you do?
What do you mean?
I really like the schrage Elsa.
That's the water.
The boiled somethings are OK.
I tend to go more for grilled, but that's
OK.
It's not a huge point of disagreement with
its.
I lived in northern China for a long time
and that's how we that's how we would have
them.
That.
That's fair.
Yeah.
The grill does not seem authentic Chinese,
but I do like it.
Stephanie, I so appreciate hearing from you
today.
Thank you so much, David.
Have a good day to you.
You, too.
Wow.
Things happening in Paris.
What a what a tragedy that I am not there.